[Musique]
salut salut bienvenue sur la rubrique
dan lo donc je suis militante chez air
et d'hommes et je m'occupe de l'arbre
ppp donc en tant qu'étudiante
réunionnais je suis actuellement confiné
à paris c'est pour cette raison que je
vais vous montrer comment on fait pour
capturer ces prix dans une enseigne
parisienne pour participer aux combats
rendez vous sur l'application air et
d'hommes où notre site internet
r d om point fr une fois l'application
ou la page internet ouverte
cliquez sur la rubrique opération vécu
et sélectionnez votre territoire vous
obtiendrez le relever b q et vous
arriverez ensuite sur un formulaire
choisissez le magasin dans la bande
déroulante puis sélectionnez votre
produit noté le prix que vous avez
relevé vous pourrez ainsi prendre la
photo rayons afin que nous puissions
savoir où se trouve le produit puis
validé par la suite prenez la photo du
produit et de même validé enfin prenez
la photo du code-barres valider cette
photo permettra également de connaître
la qualité du produit sur une
application com uk
voilà c'est fini envoyez et vous avez
terminé merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à notre chaîne
n'oubliez pas également de liker et
partagez merci de rejoindre notre combat
sur république et développement autres
mr r d om point fr à bientôt pour une
autre vidéo tutoriel l'eau